hey guys dr berg here in this video i
want to introduce you to a new product i
just came out with called
electrolyte powder okay so what's unique
about this
is that it doesn't have any sugar it
doesn't have any
maltodextrin it has a thousand
milligrams of potassium citrate
that is very very safe on your body and
you hypothetically could use this to
enhance your potassium if you're not
consuming enough vegetables you could
even do
three or even four servings to reach
your
maximum dosage of about 47 to 5 000
milligrams
but here it has the calcium potassium
magnesium
chlorides and sodium and trace minerals
71 ionic trace minerals all in one blend
and this is a touch of stevia with some
natural flavorings
of raspberry and lemon so it tastes good
put in water
dissolve it up drink it up and it's used
mainly to enhance your exercise
performance
most electrolyte powders have sugar and
it lowers your performance
this is also great to support a
healthier cardiovascular system
and improve your energy so there's four
main things that electrolytes do number
one
they help your fluids they help hydrate
you they prevent from dehydration
they help fluid move it in and out of
the cell
okay so they're great it's great for
like edema or swelling things like that
it's also supports the nervous system so
the nerves need electrolytes for the
rhythm
prevent palpitations prevent tetany
that's that little twitching on the eye
or a little
or throughout the body improve and help
balance the heart rate
okay that's mainly potassium help
influence the ph so your ph is just
correct
so the electrolytes and ph work together
if your
electrolytes are off that can throw off
your ph if your ph is off that can throw
out your electrolytes
and also primarily it affects muscle
physiology
the contraction and relaxation of the
muscle and then of course if you don't
have that you get cramps
weakness or a spasm okay so i put a link
down below to get more information
check it out and i think i think you'd
find this quite
helpful